jacob junis who has tightened up his
beard and
his midsection that's a
sleek looking jacob junius warming up
let's hope that the ball the cleveland
indians are going to try to hit looks
sleek and small too and he can have some
success here's amanda rosario the indian
shortstop
and only three runs driven in
hits that hard right field it's deep
back is olivares he's out of room it's
off the wall and ahmed can fly he's
around second on his way to third he's
gonna go for it inside the park home run
here he comes here's the throw forget
about it ahmed rosario coming up a
little gimpy but for now it's an inside
the park home run let's hope he's okay
what a start for amid rosario slicing
away from oliveros
and he goes near the wall doesn't come
up with it the ball ricochets and look
at rosario go man that's a fun trot
around the bases that wasn't the trot
that was a sprint now jose ramirez up
there
and ramirez is down on strikes so junas
makes an adjustment after
falling behind three and one ramirez
thought that he made contact but home
plate umpire lance marksdale says no and
that's out number two zach please sack
will be the indian starting pitcher
tonight zach is 8-4 making start number
20. he had 16 hits on the trip and
scored 10 runs
1-0 pitch lined over the shortstop into
left center field narrowfield is on with
the lead off single
now bradley zimmer leads off in the
second jacob junis brings it in
started to swing and he did that is a
strikeout and strikeout number two for
jake jonas
there's a line driving a right field and
a single for owen miller with two down
here and inning number two
catcher austin hedges
and he chased the slider away so it
ended up being an effective pitch up and
in junice has struck out three two down
for michael taylor
first strikeout for police act the
royals go one two three
it's one nothing cleveland after two in
this first about i just thought man when
he came here in april they were trying
him in center field he wasn't the same
right right but him in this ballpark
ballpark every day
wow he likes to go that way
and he shoots one in the right he's two
for two
well i'll tell you what he's going to
end the month like he started it hot
heavy great clyde clouds overhead here's
the pitch and it is in there strike
three called jacob junis with his fourth
strikeout in just three innings we head
to the bottom of the third here at
kauffman stadium it's
the indians won
the royals nothing dozier all for his
last 17.
right center long run zimmer with a nice
catch to hang on for route number two
that's not now you see that's what
you're talking about you've got good
speed in the outfield with both straw
and zimmer there and i mean when he hit
a live drive utilize the outfielder
that's nice he hit this ball and he's
going to be very dejected
because you know what you run it down
making a beautiful play
and he had plenty of time that was a
nice catch justin out look at zach that
a boy cleveland has the lead as we head
to the fourth inning of play foreign
bradley zimmer and bobby bradley will be
the hitters
fastball up and in struck him out
junice has five
now bradley zimmer
again there's no way you're gonna give
up on a guy like him
junis looking good with some high
pitches here now facing nikki lopez who
hit into a double play his first time up
a strong finisher
oh and there's a base hit
johnson was playing over that way but
nikki will slide into second base with a
one-out double
the man you don't want to face in this
spot is at the plate
salvador perez
and he blew a fast ball behind him and
strikes him out nice sequence going
climbing the ladder getting it out of
the zone and carlos santana will be the
batter
a great fastball
blazak gets his third strikeout
and after four it's one nothing
cleveland
the 3-2
breaking ball missed inside ball four
hedges draws the walk and the indians
have a one out base runner straw for two
his flight out grounded out
shoots it to right field that's going to
be fair ball oh my goodness on his
winner third is johnson merrifield
fumbled it but
nobody advances further than where they
were going indians at the corners with
two down ahmed rosario the battery
rosario is two for two with an inside
the park home run
runner goes and a ground ball single
into left center field
that'll score johnson mile straw coming
around third and the throw to the plate
is not in time
how about that speed from mile straw
with him running on the pitch he's able
to come all the way around and score
it's a two out two run single for ahmed
rosario in a three nothing indians lead
to the starter jacob junis i'll tell you
what he's off and running so he's going
to get there but this is with the alleys
if you take for granted that this guy is
not going to continue to run with two
outs
i mean watch him that's just a great job
of base running
and i mean he's going to take a peek and
kyle hudson's just still going to wave
him he is i mean windmill as police act
goes back to work had a good fastball
tonight
swinging a miss he struck him out
number four for
zach policek yep three straight now
nice got him to the outside corner twice
taylor thought he was going to first
base on a walk twice he was denied
they've played pretty well against other
teams
swinging a miss another strikeout for
pleisek five consecutive strikeouts he
has one of the two royal hits they lead
the league in stolen bases they've
stolen
97. he chased one in the dirt
and strikes out that's seven k's for
playset he retires the side in order
eighth straight smile straw one for
three with a single
a ground ball in the hole and it's off
the glove of lopez in the left field a
base hit for mile straw his second of
the night and it's been the ahmed
rosario show tonight he's already three
for three
maybe more deep centerfield back is
taylor he's out of room it's out of here
ahmed rosario
what in august a four hit night of five
rbi performance and it's now five
nothing cleveland that's the fifth four
hit game of the season for ahmed rosario
well when you can cover that and you hit
it the straight away center in this
ballpark it was a slider away he knew he
hit it well he gets the foot down on
time and look at him you know it back
goes taylor he's going to run out of
room and that thing gets out that's the
big part of the ball park
here's bradley zimmer two strikeouts in
a walk 100 miles an hour ground ball the
other way single for bradley zimmer his
first hit of the night took a wide turn
but he'll hold
with a one-out single here's bobby
bradley two pop-ups and a line out to
center now the 1-0 pitch
swung on and hammered high
deep to right away
back and gone
bobby bradley
with another moon shot down the right
field line and the indians lead it seven
to nothing
and bobby bradley has his 12th homer
giving him 28 rbis
and did he tee off down the right field
line quick and turning on it
he didn't get it in there here's the set
by alex young
and alex young walks the lead off man
arlo santana with two on and two out
that is back to the middle and into
center field so that'll get a run on the
board
and carlos santana will get a base hit
so perez to seconds and 10 is at first
two out ninth inning
now benetendi
shoots one into the left field corner
and that's going to be off the wall
that'll get salvi to the plate
michael taylor swings at the first pitch
right field near the line
zimmer makes the catch book it
the indians win it 7-2 take the series
opener and go to 65 and 64 on the year
they've won nine in a row against kansas
city
you